special announcement coming in hot added
to rough and rowdy 19 December 9th I put
together one hell of a crew with talbas
fight companion show we will be watching
it live with the boys we're talking Theo
Von Joey Diaz Rampage Jackson myself
[Music]
oh goodness oh wow
what else you want tune in
right through the city like British
[Music]
if you ain't thick please don't get
involved
now Brandon
what is up fam Monday December 5th what
is popping on this glorious Monday
morning I'm fresh off the plane from
Providence Rhode Island
also known as the New England area which
is news to me but I'm learning
absolutely absolutely loved it out there
man I would 100 go back so many of the
East Coast Comics that a friends of mine
told me how great of a club it is and
they were not lying man that would be
University of Colorado
you can leave it there because we'll get
to that but uh yeah man shout out to uh
to Providence me and the boys went to
Newport I was planning to go to Cape Cod
but I guess that's a bit of a drive so
everyone's like she's got a Newport it's
just as good not as crowded they weren't
lying this place was fantastic could
live out there man if you guys didn't
have winners I could live out there it
was cold when we were there going off
these dicey bridges in the middle of a
wind and rainstorm but uh we made it man
you know as a house out there chin I
know I know she's your North Star Taylor
Swift really
news to me because everywhere I went to
this coffee shop and like oh everyone
kept going you gotta drive down Ocean
Drive it was me and three dudes like
it's beautiful scenery I was like yeah
well I'm with three dudes but I was like
yeah see the house is down there and we
went down there and uh they're not lying
that bad boy was uh
pretty cool to see
see Taylor Swift's house from a distance
and it is it's uh looks like a Dave and
Buster's it's a giant giant house it's
ridiculous out there man they shot uh
The Great Gatsby out there those giant
houses the original great gas he was
shot there
yeah that's our house man beautiful yeah
it's so dope right it's the Atlantic
Ocean right there too it's it's it is
Living Desert I can only imagine Summers
must be popping out there you probably
don't want to go in the summer I guess
fall spring you've been down there case
like if you're on the East Coast that's
everything's like kind of an hour away
like fans are like where you come from
like uh Boston or something or you know
Massachusetts so many people from
Massachusetts I'm like it's that close
like yeah dude it's like 10 minutes away
I'm like I have no idea how it works on
it it's so confusing everything's so
like close it's crazy but yeah shout out
to uh
Newport man Newport Providence Rhode
Island fantastic it was so dang good out
there man I loved it so shout out to the
comic connection and uh you brought up
their chin my boy uh Dion Sanders now I
did say I would get a Deion Sanders
tattoo on my neck and I regret that
I regret that and uh
you know he's coming to University of
Colorado to pay him the big bucks he's
dude his I'm sure I'm fine with the kid
well we have that John uh Christine so I
don't know if he's a football fan so
he's not probably won't cover it and
Brian doesn't know football so I'll talk
about it here I guess but so funny
because he did his first meeting he flew
so it was kind of swirling the rumors
that he was gonna come and then I that's
why I post I said I have a good source
that the deal with Dion is done because
I have a guy where to see you I'll leave
it at that he's like it's done man he's
coming like holy crap is this real
because you understand Man City football
used to I mean it's a Powerhouse but if
you're you know the last
especially about five years have been
tough man they're one in 11 this year
awful you can't watch them so soft they
lost what
um you know used to be the heart and
soul of uh Boulder Colorado there I
don't I don't know what happened but uh
getting Dion the reason it's such a big
deal not that he's some
head coach Mastermind it's that it's
Dion Sanders so all the recruits want to
be like him and they follow him so
already one he touched down it got
announced like the number one receiver
in the nation committed to see you and
the most gangster thing you will see I
bet Barstool probably post it it's the
most gangster thing because he has a
meeting with the team he has a meeting
with the the current team he's 111. you
know somebody all better get in that uh
transfer protocol he said because I'm
come with luggage and it's Louie you're
not all you gonna be on the team in here
and you're like but why would you keep
all those losers around you know I get
it he's like and then his son's right
there he's transferring to he's like
there's your starting quarterback right
there so that's starting quarterbacks in
that room for this year he's like okay
I'm probably gonna have to hit that
transfer protocol
so it's just he's gonna change things
around like this man now you know you
got it takes a few years you look at the
FSU coach takes him about three years
you know but
there's only one place to go in Boulder
Colorado and that's up but um they used
to get the big time recruits and then
somewhere along the line they lost lost
their way but
um it's go time baby it is freaking go
time it's probably in their uh uh
website Junior I don't follow them on
social media too much
yeah he uh it's a big big deal biggest
news in Boulder and a hot hot second hot
second coach oh there goes coach Prime
basically told the entire Colorado team
to hit the transfer protocol on his
first meeting it's so Savage I don't
know if we'll be able to play this we're
gonna get docked but it's so Savage he's
like what's up yeah everyone needs to
get their [ __ ] together watch this all
right because they're probably excited
it's Deion Sanders cool so I want y'all
to get ready
to go ahead and jump in that portal
go ahead and jump that portal
do what we got to do
they're smart say that smart tough
does it I mean you should be like okay
probably good
get a new job I mean that's what you got
to do though you can't have that loser
mentality around clearly they're not
doing something right I can't believe it
man I can't believe it
it's insane made my weekend made my
freaking weekend dude
there's a big difference for him you
know don't get it twisted but also
I think this is news but uh I think see
the offense yeah it's the offense or
defense coordinator from Alabama is
going to come over to see you too he's
already on his way over as well so
that's the big deals the offense defense
coordinator because Dion will bring the
talent and bring the attitude and bring
the notoriety and then you need the
offense and defensive masterminds to
really make sure that's a championship
team so they can do it man it's Deion
Sanders baby Prime Time and Boulder God
get your mind right kids get your
freaking mind right he has some work to
do though because this is this isn't
Jackson State you're you're in the
Pac-12 you know if you you USC UCLA
Washington you have some Oregon get some
tough tough teams to compete with it's
going to you know people probably
expecting a complete turnaround from 1
and 11 11 and one that ain't happening
but if he wins say six games or seven
games first year that's insane insane so
there's gonna be a lot of pressure on
him but you can get it done
he can definitely get done but
you know that his his
winning ways at Jackson state is a far
cry from you know winning big boy games
at a high level at University of
Colorado man they get a lot of work to
do you know the the conference the teams
he's playing her
garbage it's called what it is but he
did completely turn that program around
so there's no reason and everyone starts
somewhere you know what I'm saying
everyone like I think Urban Meyer
started at Bowling Green you know
they're gonna start somewhere now
Bowling Green is a huge step up from
Jackson State right but you start
somewhere you gotta start somewhere baby
with that shout out to Boulder I'll be
going to games now
I went to game last year the one we
talked to the team I was like who are
they playing there at UFC I'm like I'm
gonna sit this one out I don't need
another L on my record I'm all set on
that let's take a little break kids for
me chatting your ears off about the
fight game because another epic night of
fights is here yeah I'm talking about
UFC 282 and before that on Friday you
have bar stool Sports rough and rowdy
yep it's going down your boy partnered
up with him you're gonna Cowboy pen for
a rough and rowdy 19 this Friday at 5
p.m Pacific on thick boy YouTube live I
have Theo Von Donald cowboy Cerrone
Rampage Jackson myself will all be
chiming in on the chaos chaos of rough
and rowdy and then while you're betting
on the fights with DraftKings you can
watch the Cowboys fight campaign live at
7 pm Pacific on thick boy for UFC 282
with Brian Kellen Sam tripley and a very
special guest and myself all right so
you're gonna be throwing down some money
on the bets this weekend make sure it's
with my friends at DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the UFC this Saturday new customers can
bet just five dollars all right
pre-fight money line on any fighter to
win and get one hundred and fifty
dollars in free bets if they do check
this out right now everyone can earn up
to 50 boost when you place a same game
parlay on the UFC 282. listen if you
want to go with the dogs you can take
till you can take freaking yawn uh
blockovich to get it done and you can
also take uh Robbie Lawler
that's a fun parlay big dogs a lot of
pay out there tough one to pull off I'm
just saying it's something you could do
I'm excited uh to bet on a lot of these
fights again the prop bets on young
could be fun with his power and takedown
defense but overall probably gonna lose
that fight download the app right now
use promo code shop show schab show bet
five dollars pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win and get 150 dollars in
free bets if they do that's code shop
show this Saturday at draftking
Sportsbook the official Sports button
partner of the UFC minimum age
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details DraftKings promo code
Shop show this episode of the shop show
is brought to you by my boys at manscape
tis the season for clean balls our
friends at manscaped are helping you
clear your driveway for safe travels
this holiday season from stocking
stuffers to white elephants manscapes
products are at the top of every dude's
wish list or your grandma's mustache
grab some crop mops for your props or
the body buffer for the holiday lover
win this year's white elephant gift and
help all the Bros in your life go from
eggnog to nice hog this December and
save 20 off and free shipping by going
to manscape.com this gift is fantastic
any dude in your life maybe he's your
man's maybe it's your grandpa your dad
step dad step Aunt you've got some hairy
shoulders this is going to help them out
they got to get the Platinum package 4.0
and boy is it loaded with so many
goodies all right we gotcha you get all
sorts of great stuff you get the
lawnmower 4.0 oh all right does your dad
have nasty nose hairs all right we'll
help him out the weed whacker nose ear
hair trimmer the shears two point is
their full kit for the Nail Care with
scissors your dad has those big talents
those big Raptor towns hanging off his
feet not anymore step snip snip all
right there's the new preserved cologne
that brings light Breezy woodsy feel and
gives that fresh tree scent all right
and if you're still
trying to get that body right get the
body buffer we got you covered man man
escaped is here to make holiday shopping
a blast by giving products that you know
your guys are going to love in your life
right and also make them laugh talk
about their hogs on Christmas they love
that save twimp stuff and free shipping
by going to manscape.com
that's right 20 off in free shipping by
going to manscape.com shop manscape the
perfect gift that will be the holiday's
biggest hit manscaped but uh let's get
into the fights man we have a big week
um
yeah touring is wrapped up for 2022.
your boy could use a little break from
traveling your boys put on some miles I
still have these nuts hanging off my
eyes put on some miles so Providence was
the last uh tour date of the year we'll
have a green room diary dropping in
Providence and then uh yeah chilling
here man but when I say chilling not
chilling but at least I'm on a flight at
least I'm sleeping my own bed which
makes all the difference in the world no
complaints best kicking in the world
just saying your boy needs a break from
the road for a little bit we pick up in
January hope we have a big announcement
coming in January probably coming up
north see my Canadian boys and the gals
but you know what I'm saying it's real
[ __ ] Fest for me uh
but uh as far as this week goes we have
man we have uh some big guests on firing
the kid we have a big guest on food
truck we have
um a good guess on the golden hour and
then we have
two fight campaigns Friday is the bar
stool uh thick boy collab where we're
doing a fight companion for rough and
rowdy which is at 5 p.m this freaking
Friday that's December 9th at 5 p.m on
thick boy YouTube it's live for the
rough and rowdy in Providence Rhode
Island
all right coincidence I don't think so I
don't think so okay so that's going down
December 9th and uh me and my boy Jeff
died did a uh Fight Night flashback for
it going over some of the fighters that
are coming up on the card this Friday so
much fun it is rough and rowdy if you've
you've I'm sure you've seen klepto you
heard about it it is so damn
entertaining it's so fun it's so fun we
watched some lady from uh West Virginia
with no teeth beat up this hot girl
wrestler we watch some dude just in the
crowd was like I'll fight that gang turn
on he's fighting the six nine dude he's
like some construction worker there's
this uh uh trap Zilla the form or he
probably is a current stripper he's a
male stripper just beats the brakes off
this young man and his tenacion pace is
insane
um yeah you have Pac-Man Jones fighting
it's just entertaining as hell it's so
much fun so I put together one hell of a
crew for the very first
bar stool Sports rough and rowdy and
calabas Fight Club thick boy collab and
we have a change in the lineup and it
breaks my heart to say this but don't
worry I'm making it up to you guys Joey
Diaz cannot leave New Jersey his book is
dropping and he messed up his schedule
so he can't come out to LA on that
Friday and make it happen so I called up
another big dog going all right Joey
I'll figure it out and we have Donald
cowboy Cerrone filling in for the great
Joey Coco Diaz you got Donald Cerrone
one of the very best ever grace that UFC
Octagon his WC days he's a living legend
and he is filling in so you have Donald
Cerrone Rampage Jackson Theo Von and my
thick ass Friday at 5 p.m live on thick
boy YouTube and then Saturday you have
UFC 282 the big boy pay-per-view in Los
Vegas and your main event is Patty
pamlett that's a Pete people's Main
Event must be real versus Jared Gordon
and then you have Jan blockovich and
magumed uh fighting for the light
heavyweight title you have Robbie Lawler
Santiago potsinibio you have Darren till
duplicates tough fight for him uh Bryce
Mitchell to Peoria you have a
rosenstruke a Dukakis you got it all
popping Daddy and for that fight
companion on Saturday for UFC 282 I have
the living legend himself the Hot Tub
Time Machine comic should have been
canceled years ago but he's not famous
enough but he's so goddamn funny and
talented you have Sam tripley he's got
Brian Callan and a very special guest
I'm waiting to announce I don't want to
take the shine away from Barstool right
now but I'm gonna drop a big name come
on that companion and that's at 7 pm
Pacific so your boy although I'm off the
road is a working so you have the bar
Shield companion and kabas Fight Club
for rough and rowdy going down Friday
December night at 5 PM you have the
calabas fight campaign with brown
account Sam tripley a very special guest
and my thick ass Saturday at 7 p.m
that's all on uh YouTube live thick boy
get you some I'm so excited man I can't
wait and surrounding man me and that
dude go back go way back such a great
dude love Donald Trump love the Donald
the Cerrone before we get into UFC 282
this weekend that card is popping I know
the main events often you guys are sad
about it I'm not I'm excited for this
I'm actually more excited for John
magamed and then also I'm glad to see my
boy Patty pimlet get bumped up to the
command event and we'll get to that
before we do yeah some fights this
weekend obviously the well I won't say
the biggest fight the biggest fight is
probably Tyson Fury right
doesn't fear you got it done surprise
Sometimes the best heavyweight to ever
do it of all time I'd love the debate if
you think you know your box and you want
to debate the greatest heavyweights to
ever do it and you have Mike Tyson or
Muhammad Ali or George Foreman or
um
it's about all he could go there I guess
you could klitschka if you want is long
rain although it's so boring
um yeah bring him on I'm down to have
that debate with anybody out there but
uh
Tyson Fury got it done 10th round TKO
looks phenomenal
um I think he has to have surgery she's
gonna be out for a little bit but he
called out uh of course Joshua by the
time that fight happens you have a Manny
Pacquiao Floyd
Mayweather situation
um so he called out
um oh then usick came in the ring yep so
usick's the only man on the planet who
has the skills to beat Tyson Fury uh if
you're a Tyson Fury fan that's the one
fight that you should be worried about
there ain't another heavyweight in this
world who's gonna be Tyson Fury usik has
the skill set to beat Tyson Fury usick
is a bad mama jama
um he can go Toe to Toe form technique
wise
um he is a straight up Savage
the reason you'd probably lean on Fury
uh level of difficulty of guys that he's
beat uh the power and then also the size
advantage
Tyson Fury is my favorite firing Combat
Sports period primary one top two
favorite athletes in any sport period I
absolutely adore Tyson Fury that's the
one fight I wouldn't bet my
kids college tuition on usik is very
very scary and very very sound
technically and also his mindset is
insane he's a scary scary man if you see
his fights against Anthony Joshua
then Joshua's a bigger man size was not
a problem there he bullies dudes bully
dudes you see what he did in his amateur
career in the Olympics he's a [ __ ]
prom for anybody real problem so if
Tyson Fury is going to get do that fight
he needs to do it soon before Father
Time creeps up on him because he's gonna
have to give his best performance he he
can't show up like he did against Wilder
the first or second fight
um he can't show up like you did uh you
know in this last fight he'd have to be
a better version Tyson Fury which I
think maybe Lucy can bring that out of
him but uh the main fights that he
called out usick is the one fight oof
I'm curious what the odds would be on
that
and if I was in such a Tyson Fury nut
gobbler I would probably put money on
music but I'm biased and you guys know
this we've watched this show long enough
Tyson Furious minus 280.
I like money
you know it's not a Bad Bet then that's
right now so the money you know how they
do these odds they want to put they want
to change people put money on the other
guy so uh yeah yeah Gypsy King you know
I don't see him losing you know but it's
not bad bet if you like to make money
but so I would say that was the best
fight of the weekend but the most uh if
you're watching this show you're not
probably you probably have the biggest
boxing fan so you guys around the water
cooler at work today or if you're still
at home zooming in you're still probably
near some water
um uh by the sink and you're talking to
yourself or you're watching this and
listening
um Wonder Boy and uh Kevin Holland was
the Talk of the Town of the UFC world
you had Wonder Boy The Man Thompson
Wonder Man Thompson versus Kevin Holland
it was so God dang entertaining
um and I love this and I don't think
Kevin Holland loses any stock here I
don't think he lost any stock whatsoever
when he fought homside on a 32nd notice
which was a complete uh inside job just
kidding
am I though
talk about them amongst yourselves
but uh so I think Kevin Holland didn't
lose any
um you know didn't lose any hype there
and things happen in this complete
nightmare of a matchup
um all good I think we forgot about it
then he retired and came out of
retirement and then he fought Wonder Boy
Thompson and Wonder Boy and Kevin
Holland in the same where they're sick
of grappling they're sick of that stuff
and they had a gentleman's agreement to
keep this on their feet
I have a bit of a problem with that
especially if you're Kevin Han if I'm
wondering what's like hell yeah
Gentleman's Agreement keep it on the
feet because Wonderboy might be a blue
belt you know but Kevin Han's legit I
think henzo Gracie back like legit black
belt you know
not not like competition quality but in
dude has a black belt you know yeah
black belt black black belt yeah Travis
loser [ __ ] Savage
super Savage
um so you know it's no punk to have your
black belt or Travis looter so it's
pretty uh pretty impressive so for Kevin
Holland
you know on on the feet clearly you know
I picked Kevin Hall to win that fight
thinking father time to catch up with
one of boy Thompson and it really hasn't
but also for Kevin Holland you know I
said he has black belt and crazy he had
to get pretty wild and mix it up with
Stephen one boy Thompson and Wonder Boy
just had his timing really lit him up I
think uh huge takeaways Kevin Holland's
chin he ate some major shots like
rushing it takes the I mean kicks all
day to the head and then you know he
didn't really shoot about the first two
rounds first two or three rounds maybe
shot in the third definitely shot in the
fourth
um
the gentleman's agreement I get it it's
entertaining and the fans like it and we
respect and I respect Kevin Hahn more
than anything in the world and obviously
one boy I've known him forever I love
Wonder Boy Thompson
um I saw some funny meme it says uh when
they call me old I call them an
ambulance
he's not lying he [ __ ] dudes up dude so
for Kevin Holland it's It's just tough
man because we do this Gentleman's
Agreement you take away literally the
biggest Advantage you have in this fight
because on the Feet's not your biggest
Advantage you'd say pal you know Kevin
Holland has a Advantage when it comes to
the power when he lands but I still
would say he has a bigger Advantage if
that fight would hit the floor and
Wonder Boy Thompson
um you know he's just defensive he's not
offensive Jiu Jitsu guy his defense
isn't great down there from his Guard
from half Guard from Mount from his back
stuff like that he's uh okay but if
you're a black belt you can drag in
those deep Waters and can get pretty
dice for a guy at a blue belt level so
Kevin Holland a huge Advantage there and
you do a gentleman's agreement coming
off a loss you know I just
as much as we respect it if I'm his
coaches and team I just so hey dude
forget this Jones agreement let's let's
have Wonder Boy thinking we're going to
take him down it's going to only open up
the Striking more which is what you want
to do and also when you get him down if
the submissions there go for it man we
need wins like you need wins especially
in the welterweight division you need
wins because that Jones agreement
doesn't pay your mortgage that
Gentleman's Agreement doesn't extend
your contract in the UFC The Dana whites
of the world and the the Nick Maynards
who do the uh you know matchmaking don't
care about a gentleman's agreement they
care if the fight's exciting but at the
end of the day do not get it twisted
they are not your friend as much as Dana
goes I hope he's not retired he's such
an exciting fighter at the end of the
day and I've been in those meetings
it doesn't matter how exciting it was if
you lost they will hold it against you
at all costs when you go to renegotiate
your contract at all cost it's the one
thing they will fall back on anybody
that's exciting like we don't care you
didn't get a win so it's it's a dicey
road because obviously the fans and in
myself included respect the gentleman's
agreement and man it's so much that
fight was so fun oh my God that fight
was fun I mean if Kevin Hall didn't
break his hand you're talking about
fight of the Year damn near it was so
goddamn exciting and and when Wonder Boy
know he's not getting taked down he's
just teeing off don't you you've never
seen before and there's pictures of his
entire first just on Kevin Holland's
face and [ __ ]
um that was so fun
but fun doesn't pay your mortgage or
your bills so that's the only thing you
know we all respect and I'm sure he's
getting a lot of love online but at the
end of the day it's very black and white
and you guys especially the the MMA fan
base two years from now three years from
now a lot of you will forget this but
that was a fun fight oh yeah but he lost
you know so it's very black and white
wins and losses so as much as I expect
the gentleman's agreement it's about
winning fights at all costs whatever
that is and his biggest advantage in
that fight was to get him down and
submit him but you wanted to put on a
show and you know you're hoping UFC well
you know
reward you for putting on that
performance but it doesn't really work
like that they don't really reward off
that stuff asked Chris Weidman when he
cut 40 pounds in two days you know and
they told told him they were gonna take
care of them against the thing it was
Damian you know what they did nothing it
just there's nothing to contract and
they'll use that to their defense to to
you know management changes and that
ain't happening anytime soon especially
before Kevin Holland retires so you got
to take care of yours you really do man
and again we respect it but the end of
the day it's gonna bite you in the ass
so I just want to give it all and get a
win I did pick him to win
I broke his hand you know he can't
predict a handbrake and who knows what
would have happened if he didn't break
his hand yes one was teeing off on him
the speed of Wonder Boy
um eyes maybe I'm multiple you guys tell
me
um everyone see the fight in here and
when I say you guys tell me fans too
what you do you remember when Pat Berry
flat Crow got me in so much respect like
how he's like blasting the face then
hugging and clapping and like slapping
cheeks and [ __ ]
when Kevin Holland and one boy like do
something cool and they're like oh that
was cool like high five in or when Kevin
Holland's like damn you need to slow
down like it's a great again it's a
great sound bite and social media loves
it but I feel like when you do that you
take it's taking you out of that kind of
that Championship mentality it's like
taking out of that like to win at all
cost like even if a guy was faster than
me or to some you know some of the
Champions they would never give that up
I'm not giving that guy a [ __ ] inch
even if like crocod was the strongest
guy I ever thought I never never years
later the strongest I ever fought I
never gave him that ever I don't give
him an inch so I feel like she when you
give that stuff up
when you do give up that stuff and
especially during the height in the in
the mix of the [ __ ] fight I just feel
like you're you're losing that kind of
Killer Instinct you know but Kevin
Holland
who am I to critique him you know he's a
guy who's always been entertaining he's
entertainment first you'd see his walk
out he's cool as a cucumber great walk
out singing and then he also he's known
for talking you know inside that octagon
we love it we absolutely love it but
when you don't win it's tough man
winning takes care of every problem you
have
social media is not paying the bills
social media doesn't you know as much as
people love that talking and you know
you making this Gentleman's Agreement
yeah man this is fantastic at the end of
the day the UFC is going to hold it
against you now if the UFC was like that
Gentleman's Agreement man you do that we
guarantee you give you the best two
match-ups next and you're only gonna
fight stand-up guys then yeah hell yeah
do that they don't do that they know you
lost man
probably not main event next you know
you well be you well see the
repercussions from losing a fight no
matter how what happens if it was
entertaining if you broke your hand they
do not care at the end of the day they
the circus moves the [ __ ] on you're
stuck with a broken hand recovering and
he's gonna have to have surgery they
said you know
so uh for Wonder Boy you know he looked
phenomenal and he said this to you see
what happens when you give me Strikers
like stand-up guys like how fun was this
if you guys like entertaining fights
keep giving me Stand Up Guys but really
the eye is on the prize to be the world
champion so if that's a possibility then
give me the next guy to get me closer to
the Belt otherwise she's giving me these
fun fights like Kevin Hong was even
ranked I don't think so he's like keep
giving me the fun fights I don't care
what the rank keep giving me fun fights
I'm with Wonder Boy can you give him the
fun fights he's gonna light some people
up he'll go on a four fight win streak
then give him a guy who's in the top
three and he wins that and then he's
gonna title shot who don't like Wonder
Boy
you know
yeah you look at the the list there uh
one boy six
yeah they didn't have them they didn't
have them ranked up there huh
so they did give him the fight of the
night bonus but I get what you're saying
as far as negotiations down the line
it's wins that matter yeah 50 50 Grands
nothing but you know I'm not saying 50
Grand is not a lot of money 50 Grand is
a [ __ ] ton of money I'm saying in the
grand scheme of things if this is his
book 50 Grand is a short short chapter I
think about the book I think about long
term you gotta win yeah that's all I'm
saying I can get enough of the fight
doing what I love about the East Coast
I got done with my show on Saturday
night drove from Providence Rhode Island
to Boston at 11 o'clock got there around
11 45 11 50. and I was able to see dos
Angels uh barbarina and then I also got
to see one boy Kevin Hall in the full
fight Ali it's 12 30 at night the east
coast is wild dude this is fantastic it
was great it was great man
so I'm sure for one boy if you go back
to the welterweight rankings there
um
you know if he doesn't care about
um rankings and he and he's not trying
to yeah those those gentlemen ranked
ahead of him will be a problem Muhammad
hamzaad of course Colby Usman
best matchup for Wonder Boy if they want
to be champ he'd have to jump the cue
and we've seen them do this I appear
right if he jumps the Q and he fought
Leon Edwards no way ain't nobody
shooting in that fight Leon Edwards and
uh Wonder Boy could happen you know so
if that's what he wants to do USC
planning and do that uh chambray be a
nightmare if you can't get him down
um he fought Vicente Luke
uh miles Vidal yep they've uh uh Neil
Maggie scroll down one more this has to
be someone in the top 15. oh there you
go uh Michael uh I'm Michelle pajer yeah
yeah Michelle Pierre would be a
fantastic fight I'll stand up then
Daniel Rodriguez too great two two
gentlemen
you know and I would I would favor one
boy over both of them one boy could rip
off easily three wins in a row you just
beat homeboy in Holland big win and then
you got yeah uh pierra and then Daniel
Rodriguez I would favor one win all
those fights and they're so fun those
could be Main Event fight nights all
[ __ ] night all night
all night
uh dos anjos beat Brian barbarino Brian
barbarina was on the Legends tour just
wrecking dudes careers and then he ran
to dosanjos Dos Santos is I think 38
one of my favorite people on the planet
was the only Brazilian who was nice to
me when I was getting ready to fight
nogira I always talk about that I will
never forget as long as I live so he's
38. I can't believe he's doing three he
has the most octagon time out of any
fighter in the UFC which is insane
um
and he called out uh Conor McGregor I
actually liked the fight when he you
know what everyone calls out Connor
um
to me this makes the most sense for Khan
I know Connor wants to fight you know
Michael Chev and stuff like that it's
not happening but this makes the most
sense because a at 170 kind of ain't
making 55 for quite some time so at 170
he doesn't have to kill all that weight
he's a big boy right now you know Rogan
alluded to it I was like it's true you
melt the [ __ ] cup if you pissed and
you saw the cop you know which so
whatever you want to draw your
conclusions there
um so yeah he's probably in a similar
stack to you know uh liver King whatever
they're both lying to us just kidding
um but so
dos anchos Connor makes all this when
you think at first I was like ah who
calls out of course he calls out Connor
say that's never gonna happen I thought
about him like
I could see that happening remember
they're supposed to fight he got hurt
and he fought Chad Mendes so they're
they're supposed to fight there's a deep
history there they've gone to fisticuffs
before at the AP Institute you know in
Vegas
API the pi Institute in Vegas so they do
not like each other there's a history
there you know dos Angels 38 longer in
the tooth uh Connor's take down the
fence is phenomenal on the feet kind of
have Advantage it goes the ground
clearly dos Santos have an advantage it
makes a lot of sense he's not a it's a
older RDA he's not the tip of the spear
right now kind of needs to get a win
when I laid my head down at night when I
couldn't sleep in that hotel uh you know
in uh Boston I thought ah man that's
exactly what I do if I'm cutter I go
after RDA
history there and bring up that old
footage gets him back on the winning
track I assume he'd be a slight favorite
some of these other guys calling out
don't make a lot of sense because if
you're a Conor fan which you know first
email Connor here fan base
um he needs to fight a smart fight on
his comeback fight you have to that's
his smartest fight
yeah Connor minus one oh wait that was
back in the day way back out this is
when they first
so
Connor was
whoa
Connor's plus 115 back then at the time
yeah remember that that's that's a older
dos angels now
it just makes a lot of sense I dig it
and this one from odd shark is plus 124
RDA no see that's that's February 23rd
yeah 2016. it's super old yeah yeah the
old one yeah yeah I would assume now
yeah the odds on that'd be tough because
I kind of fought for a while
RJ's been doing just beat barbarina you
know right dosanos probably still slight
favorite probably a minus 120 you know
and then probably the MVP
um
my boy um Aleister who bets on all the
fights and his brother I guess you can't
bet in Providence there's no online
betting there they like banned it for
whatever reason like DraftKings whatever
so he had his brother he told his
brother put 20 on a parlance brother put
like 200 on it he's like holy [ __ ] if I
win this party I win like 40 G's like
who would you bet on and he had Kyle
dockets over Eric Anders which I told
him I didn't like at the time
um I think he had tied to avasa and
Kevin Holland
so you know he lost all his money yeah
um but the MVP of the night I would say
is uh Sergey dude he was a
now remember his first fight in UFC ever
was against ouster over him and he lost
that fight
how hey how good is Alistair over him B
how good is Sergey he's gone on to do
work
so ouster knocked him out in China his
first fight ever tough fight
um and then he's being he's gone on to
do some work man listen he beat Derrick
Lewis knocked out artist in 55 seconds
and they beat taito Vasa who beat Derek
Lewis again knockout artist was one
fighter went away from fighting for a
title Derek Lewis fought for a title
right he beat Derek Lewis and tied to
avasta all under a minute he had a new
real threat on your hands I'd probably
say Sarah gone snack for him
tough fight for that Russian gentleman
tough fight again another [ __ ]
Russian dude they're taking over
they're taking over I told you guys
they're taking over
but yeah that would be your uh
that'd be your MVP of that of that of
the night Sergey Pavlich is a problem
he's gonna get a big fight how can you
not one more and then get a title shot
if you add heavyweight to win five in a
row and you beat Derek Lewis and tied to
avasa
them ranked fifth
uh yeah probably fighter zero gone
or Stipe
because he beat Tai so he'll jump up to
four right Curtis blades doesn't have a
fight
yeah depends what they want to do I
think sir gone's the best and it all
this predicate off Jon Jones and then
getting a deal done with Francis because
that gets down here Francis Jon Jones
you do man
you guys can get dicey because curse
blade seems to fight Stephen needs to
fight zero gone and then Sergey Pavlich
needs a fight and Tom aspinall on online
on on Instagram back training so he'll
come back soon too
tell you what
John does his thing right gets a big win
Tom gets healthy time could be a problem
for John
that's a fun one there's so many fun
fights for John
the heavyweight division is kind of
popping right now
I'm not mad at it
now a word from our sponsor at
betterhelp I've been a better help user
for quite some time now man
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual so it's not working out for
you it's normal if you feel a little
stuck navigating any of life's
challenges can make you feel unsure was
a career change a new relationship you
become a parent that's a lot to take on
man therapists are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills they're basically like they're
coaches for you man to figure life out
and better help has connected over three
million people with licensed therapists
it's convenient and it's accessible
anywhere and again it's a hundred
percent online whether or not you've
been in therapy all right you need to
try it out because there's no reason not
to you don't have to drive you don't be
self-conscious about it you can do it
anytime you want they link you up with a
therapist and you get going all right as
the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professional licensed vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable much cheaper than
in-person therapy just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a perfect
therapist if things aren't clicking can
easily switch a new therapist all good
it could be any simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist try it out man you don't
know till you try it don't be scared
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com shop Schaub
that's betterhelp help help.com shop
this episode of the shop show is also
brought to you by my fave good to see
him up here my fave listen if you're a
regular viewer of this show you've been
doing my
comedy shows on the road which we just
got done with our last date you'll see
me on stage you'll see me in the Green
Room you see me around your city you see
me on podcasts you see me all over your
city using Rogue nicotine I use their
pouches every single day I use them on
my podcast at the gym while I'm driving
I mean everywhere my favorite flavor is
the Apple I like the lemon
I like mango uh the berries cool to
switch it up I love all their flavors
the peppermint they got it all man all
right you can get in all sorts of
flavors like Wintergreen peppermint
mango Citrus they got it all Rogue also
makes other great products like gum
tablets lozenges I love that I can take
it anywhere I want take it on the plane
take the comedy clubs there's no
restrictions Rogue is my go-to source
for nicotine when I'm riding performing
whatever I'm doing you see me with Rogue
nicotine and I love it that's why I
asked them be part of this program
that's why I reached out to them I was
like hey I use a product more than
anything I use in my life please jump on
board they went say less all right if
you want to try pouches like your boy
here or the gums or tablets everyone get
your nicotine go to Rogue nicotine.com
use the code rogue20 for 20 off your
order again that's Rogue 20 for 20 off
your order under ages underage sale is
prohibited warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is the addictive
chemical for more information visit
roguenicotine.com Roe 20 for 20 off your
order that's Rogue 20 for 20 off your
order the best nicotine on the planet
Last Read kids I promise gotta keep
these street lights on baby someone has
to pay for my rogue nicotine and this
episode of the shop show is also brought
to you by my favorite supplements on the
planet you don't have to worry about
getting in trouble if using on it
supplements nope did the best
supplements the safest supplements on
planet Earth they got it all Alpha Brain
new mood total gut health they have
krill oil joint oil shroom Tech they got
freaking protein powders for you
creatine glutamine they got it all man
they got MCT oil whey protein they have
protein bites they even got coffee they
have freaking fat Butters they have
Fitness Gear for your thick ass
kettlebells they have on-demand
streaming Fitness on it in 30 steel Club
Macy's steel Macy's quad maces home
fitness programs on at six barbell body
weight durability kettlebell steel Club
steel mace on its extreme and fitness
programs say what on it sandbags battle
ropes they have the best nootropic on
the planet over 1 million bottles sold
we're talking about Alpha Brain that's
right you've heard my friend Joe Rogan
talk about it you've heard every anybody
who's into nootropics they talk about
Alpha Brain you can try it out it's your
guaranteed work or your money back if
you don't like it the refund your money
you don't have to send the product back
go ahead and keep it but that's how sure
Anna is of their nootropics it's the
best man all right so you can save 10
off Alpha Brain or any product I just
mentioned by going to
audit.comit.com
and you save ten percent off Alpha Brain
or you can pick up alphabet at Walmart
or help your boy out use the promo code
shop audit.com shop 10 off all the
workout gear kettlebells steel Club
maces protein bars Alpha Brain
everything best supplements on planet
Earth on it.com shop now let's get back
to the freaking program
all right let's get into the big fight
card this uh Saturday UFC 282 you have
the Cowboys fight campaign with Brian
count Sam triple and myself going down
at 7 p.m Pacific live on thick boy
YouTube
um
I I love the card from top to bottom
from the from the early prelims on ESPN
Plus or UFC Fight Pass to the prelims on
ESPN uh two where you spin plus where I
watch them and then the pay-per-view uh
definitely worth the money from top to
bottom it's a great freaking card
um my boy uh Edmund shot bosian's doing
the damn thing you have uh roads and
stroke uh docus you know he's probably a
little status brother lost and then uh
the main card kicks off in every single
main card
um has a chance to
I mean it's gonna be tough to get a
bonus on this fight card it's fantastic
Bryce Mitchell uh toporia somebody's oh
has got to go uh you have Bryce flatter
Mitchell versus uh toporia
um
you know once 12-01's 15-0 uh taporia
although some would say he is a better
Striker than Bryce Mitchell
um he also fans himself with Grappler as
well because if you like his record as
of late right so k-o-k-o-k-o
but before a lot of this he you know he
got to start he's a submission guy
he's he's more of a jiu jitsu guy than a
knockout artist even though you know
he's been knocking fools out lately as
of late but if you go to Bryce
Mitchell's record chin don't get it
twisted it's not like Bryce Mitchell's
like a Ben Astron situation where his
striking's like horrible because he was
piecing up at zimbarbosa if you guys
remember back in that fight he was
piecing up at some Barboza he just think
against Andre feely you know Charles
roses no punk he's fought some pretty
tough Strikers and figures a way to get
the job done so
um I'm taking the flat earther himself
Bryce Mitchell
and that's a fight he's gonna win
because he wouldn't win in a flat Earth
debate against Mr Joe Rogan that would
not go well for him uh but I'm so
intrigued by that fight and then this
next fight
um
I'm so curious what you can go down here
you have Darren till who hasn't fought
since 2019 he's had some injuries right
had to pull out some fights he's had
some you know he had some issues outside
the octagon and the gentleman that he's
fighting they're not doing
um they don't tell any favors here at
all so darrento was supposed to fight uh
only he's supposed to fight a homeboy
the straight Grappler
was a jacket Manson or no yeah her
Manson who lost
um which again would have been a tough
fight but you know the hardcores you
guys know this the the jump duplicity
that he's fighting is a tougher fight
this is not an easy fight for tarantil
in any facet especially what he's been
going through he's changed camps things
back in Thailand training
um if you remember when Darren till was
coming up through the ranks
um he was trained a lot in Thailand kind
of doing his own thing then he we got to
do if he got with these super camps he's
gotten away from that he was always you
know he's kind of uh the P Diddy of the
fight game where he's always in
um hamzat's videos all up in the videos
you know so now he's doing his own thing
um because I think you realize what it's
going to take to uh
to get a win
um the problem is he's fighting an
absolute monster
to police he's an absolute monster
um you know his time in Poland he was a
ksw champion
um he was an EFC champion this guy is no
punk no punk
um
I'm rooting for Darren till I because if
didn't tell loses this one I just
I don't know where he goes right this is
like he he has to win this fight he has
to win this fight he's lost four out of
his last five but he's also lost to the
best of the best right he's lost a
Woodley that was a tough one on him that
was too much too soon
um he did beat Wonder Boy Beat Cerrone
right
oh
then he beat Kelvin gasum via Split
Decision I actually thought Kelvin won
that fight that was him return to
middleweight
he lost to Robert Whittaker and then he
uh lost to Derrick Brunson so you know
he's losing to the best of the best
duplicities is right up there Ben and
he's been waiting for a big fight to get
into the rankings this would do it
um
I won't bet on this fight you know
because I am biased I am rooting for
Darren till and I I just worry about him
mentally if he were to lose this fight
and he has kids right and he gets flies
off The Rocker and he has some issues so
just for the
for his mental health owner in this
fight I really do do policies can be
fine no matter what but for during till
this kind of a fork in the road he loses
this one after you know when you're
losing fights man you're doubting your
camp or your training partners then you
go to a new camp or you go back to
something that you had success with and
you're thinking that's the answer and if
you lose that fight and realize that's
not the camps it's just you that's a
tough pill to swallow that's what would
happen with Darren till here so uh I'm
I'm rooting for till to get it done here
via TKO
would not bet on this fight
uh because my head says duplicities but
my heart's going there until I'll take
there until via the win but that's gonna
be a tough one very very tough fight for
him the next one's just fun this is you
flip a coin I don't know what the odds
are odds have to be pretty close Robbie
Lawler putzanibio
flip a coin was a straight up Savage and
then oh wow Jesus Christ
when I say flip a coin
um that coin is very happy that's crazy
though it's kind of minus 410 that is
how dare you half Kings how dare you
this has finite written all over it
probably not going to decision
um it's it that's weird to bet on pots
and ebio like that at a minus 410 I know
I know Robbie law is falling on hard
times go to his record 10. I realize
following some hard times still Robbie
Lolly son of a [ __ ] and his last we
lost to barbarino
so he got knocked out by barbarina and
then he beat uh Nick Diaz and they lost
you know magni Kobe Covington Ben Astron
dosanjos he beat Cerrone then Woodley
yeah you know it's tough
the ashram thing was kind of weird too
though remember yes yeah we didn't know
if he was really out so yeah yeah
uh yeah that's a tough tough night in
the office for him he's lost a bunch uh
he's lost one two three four five six
he's lost five out of six
he's lost six out of his last eight he's
lost seven I was last nine you go to
panzanibio it's just one like
guaranteel's not active it's hard to bet
on him possible not active hard to bet
on him you know
God constantly came out guns a blazing
dude he won sheesh one two three four
five six seven in a row before your boy
the leech Lee jingling knocked his ass
out and then he beat uh Miguel and then
he's lost two via split decisions
so yeah I get why pontinobi would be a
heavy favorite there that's heavy though
that's just disrespectful man it's a
Legends match here
um yeah so again I'm gonna put money on
it my heart's with Robbie Lawler my
brain thing put all your money on pasta
nibio all your money on duplicities but
I'm not doing that
well that leads us to the people's Main
Event your co-main event if you're not a
Liverpool fan Patty pimlet versus Jared
Gordon
not an easy fight for our boy Patty in
any uh capacity but it's a perfect fight
for him where he's at in his career I
think
um
this is going to be the best out in
Patty you know you gotta assume Patty's
not gonna overlook him because
um Gordon has the skills where if he's
overlooked he will beat Patty
unfortunately we'll stop the hype train
if Patty's not firing all cylinders this
guy has that type of talent
um I do think Patty gets it done I think
he's the next big thing I think he's um
you know he has a ways to go but he does
have uh world champion written all over
him he just just got to give him time
you give him time you know the the
Jordan uh Levitt fight was a step up
um the Vargas fight was a step up so the
UFC's doing the right thing and slowly
entering them up and he's lost before
you know but I do think this is by far
his toughest task when it goes to the
ground
um you know this guy is no punk so it's
not like he's just gonna absolutely mop
the floor with him on the ground I think
if you guys are probably Patty pimlet
fan you should do some research on uh
Gordon because uh on the ground he's no
slouch he's a brown belt uh I want to
say understand her is that right Jim see
oh Hanzo Gracie Jiu-Jitsu yeah Dan her
yeah and he's at kill Cliff which is a
phenomenal School uh he's a brown belt
yeah under John Denver there you go
brown or Jen John danher which in most
cases would make you a black belt
anywhere else so he's gonna be no punk
on the ground and Patty pilmet's biggest
kind of
asset is his grappling but um
if he submits this dude you know it's
Off to the Races for Patty so you know I
do think a win here gives Paddy into the
top 15 rankings probably ranked 15th or
14th it's a perfect step for him it's a
tough step but this is also we're gonna
find a lot out about Patty pimlet I do
think Patty's gonna sell the most
pay-per-views on the entire card so
hopefully he's being compensated
um because that change of The Main Event
co-main Event
um really messes things up you know we
had Glover and Yuri fighting Glover
turns on the fight which
you know in a business sense as far as
matchmaking makes all the sense in the
world for at
Glover's age should be like no I'm not
fighting I'm supposed to fight a
straight Striker and I'm straight
fighting a straight Grappler not but
[ __ ] this I'm not doing that especially
at his age takes another loss so you
just gotta hope if you are a Glover fan
that Jan and magumed isn't like some
fight of the night and you get an
immediate rematch and that just keeps
pushing it back for an older Glover text
error because the you know father time
is
a knocking
um so to wrap that up though with the
comment event I'll take Patty pimlet and
I think he wins via decision and then
Jan blockage uh magumed
um I do think Jan has the tools to
prevent the stop the takedown early on
it just depends how how much gas he has
in the tank to get that done magomet is
just a straight up Savage uh you know uh
he's a minus 2 45 favorite for a reason
I'll take I'll take uh my command I
think he gets done via submission
submission from ground impound like TKO
you know I think it's pretty as the
fight goes on I think John
his best chance is in the first two
rounds defense takedown lands one with
heavy heavy polish shots but if he
doesn't get done in the first two rounds
he's getting taken down this can get
ugly for him and I'll take I'll take uh
Maga bed on that fight great fight
though man so I have Bryce Mitchell
Darren till don't bet on that I'm bet
with my heart
um uh
uh first rule of UFC Fight Club never
bet against Robbie Lawler pick against
Robbie Lawler that's just that's
disrespectful right it's just so rude uh
so Bryce Mitchell Darren till Robbie
Lawler don't bet on my dear and Tim
Robbie Lawler picks probably not going
to win uh that Patty pimlet be a
decision they have magmad via late TKO
submission he finished him fourth fifth
round
fun fight so
I'm excited for this bed and I get to do
a companion for it I can't wait
all right chin what do you got buddy all
right oh you had one Championship too we
did yeah boy I was off of my boy RDR
he was his
the list of all his accomplishments are
in insane but when he let me see some
guy when he's seen him fight too but
then also the size difference it was the
power difference like Jesus Christ it's
like a Mack truck just running into him
Malcolm is a Savage yeah he just hits
like a straight up Mack truck
yeah that was good super fun but yeah uh
that Malkin is a problem RDR is like you
know I'm just gonna hang out at
middleweight forget this forget you big
boys those giant Russians that hit like
a Mack truck it was a great card
um and also you're bored we had him on
the show before
Brandon Vera oh yeah yeah they he fought
over the weekend as well on one
championship and he lost to
on their all that bar which we heard
about before but yeah so he retired so
Brandon actually just put his gloves out
yeah I think he's 42 years old 42. damn
[Applause]
I love you all thank you for everything
[Music]
[Applause]
of the world
[Applause]
what a great career yeah he was an intro
because he was a guy who burst on the
scene and remember a fear he beat he
beat uh that Silva dude that like
heavyweight I think and then he's like
I'm be the light heavyweight champion
the heavyweight champion of the world
and then you got a dispute contractually
and then get a little dicey for him
yeah
and Jon Jones
pretty much Jon Jones yeah ruined that
he's us three in a row tkos too that's
not fun but he was doing the damn thing
and then he was his last UFCU against
Ben Rothwell tough one trust me Rothwell
tested positive for high testosterone
even though uh they fought Shogun lost
that TKO
my boy Elliot Marshall beat him uh
that's what I'm thinking of
that guy silver false falsified his
urine sample okay yeah then he had the
Jon Jones the Randy Couture
and keep going down which fight was it
when he got in the mic was it was
against Frank Mayer that's what happened
so he gets on the mic after being Frank
Mayer in 2006 that you see 65. it's one
two eighty two people not including
fight nights so he gets out he's
starching dudes uh yeah so he submits
Silva
um oswario Silva they beat the [ __ ]
Justin L ehlers Fabio Sean sherner Mike
Whitehead who's a Savage so he's beating
this [ __ ] all these guys he's the WC uh
heavyweight champion
um and so he beats Oswego Silva for a
guilting joke I'll never forget that and
then he fights Frank Mayer in Sacramento
and remember the TKO knees are Savage
Savage he gets on Mike a zombie
lightweight heavyweight champion UFC
said cool and they took damn near entire
year off and they gave him Tim Sylvia he
was Tim Sylvia you know okay cool now
here's Febreze over Doom he loses it for
Doom yeah and then I get then he casts
the light heavyweight
and then that light heavy got dicey too
because
he lost the keys Jardine and then he
beat uh Kristoff but then they go okay
cool story here's Randy Couture and Jon
Jones you know
yeah overall
had a great career man yeah he got he
became a champion so yeah that's awesome
nicest dude ever too unfortunately he
was in uh Singapore for a hot second he
said I haven't had American he flew two
he was on his way to I think Hawaii or
some [ __ ] with his family stopped here
to do a food truck back when it was
showtime for a reason this I'm not
trying to you know not political here
the food truck was called the woke food
truck and he said I'm so excited it was
like Burger she's like I'm so excited I
haven't had American food so long it's
my first American meal can't wait and it
was the worst Food Truck you've ever had
I was like oh my God I am so sorry dude
he's like no it's good I'm like it's not
that you just haven't had good food in a
while I'm so sorry it has burgers this
burger is called the woke how hard is to
do Burgers wrong that's crazy
all right well well we've had some bad
ones well Tim Kelly had the steam Burger
years ago okay
Tim was like why are you steaming what
are you doing taking all the flavor man
because yeah that's what makes us
different he's like it's okay to make
just a good burger you don't get to be
different it's just a terrible [ __ ]
steam burger just dry
but the majority that I tried they were
awesome so oh yeah dude nine out of ten
food trucks are phenomenal
it's very rare we get a bad one yeah all
right so since we're on the topic of one
uh this just got announced oh one
Championship makes its U.S on ground
debut so
the the one Championship on Amazon have
all been you know
during hot times for America even though
it's in Singapore or wherever they're
doing that it's all been live at during
Prime Time American uh timing but now
they're actually coming to the United
States with their first headlining to
Denver Colorado
to Colorado wherever First Bank Center
is I don't know where that's at first
yeah First Bank is uh Broomfield that's
where I had my first fight well there
you go yep that's in Broomfield Colorado
so one makes its U.S on ground debut on
May 5th at the First Bank Center in
Colorado Headlines by DJ
Demetrius Johnson and Mariah's three
yeah wow
that's freaking cool man yep good for
him
how big was that Marias guy you saw him
in person Market freaking jacked
he's huge just looking on when he's
fighting Demetrius oh dude when they did
the square off you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah it's massive dude talented bastard
talented I know I said bastard Beyonce
uh I thought this is really cool I'm not
sure if we're gonna show this but I'll
just play audio so this is uh
Kevin Holland talking about Wonder Boy
yeah he's fast
so if you got me first and you're
winging your shots
[Applause]
he's like that old ass [ __ ] fast
yeah which is so true when you watch the
fight yeah
[Music]
this coach like yeah he's fast man he'll
throw straight down the center it's not
working for us
uh all right we talked about this
already
let's go Fury the music's face I know so
the biggest news I think over when it
comes to MMA is this thing God this guy
James Chris goes down a deep dark Road
huh I read a little bit about it right
so they did some more investigation it
looks like it gets pretty dicey so right
now he's suspended and also his fighter
Derek Minor he was cut from the FC
that's how serious it is right now and
this is so for the use I mean Derek mine
I think he's lost like he's won one out
of four so that makes sense that someone
put up with it but also would like to
cut him like that especially if he had
nothing to do with it they're probably
gonna come anyway but they you know
expedited the cut what makes it dicey is
so is that minor in on it too like from
their from their investigation was was
he tanking fights it seemed it seemingly
that it looks like and then where it
gets dicey what they're saying is what
cruise would do is you know he had some
rich friends and then he'd like hey take
this do this bet on this guy and how
huge of a [ __ ] it just came in out of
nowhere the betting right it was so
obvious that they had to investigate it
minor 32 faces potential sanctioned from
NS C which oversaw UFC 64 for not
disclosing the legendary he had before
his loss the commission said that
Minor's actions had all kind of effects
on betting lines in fact the odd swung
in favor of homeboy in the hours that he
was fighting games way too common yeah
nice try and the hours before the fight
uh he finishes a minus 420 favorite up
from minus 220. so those Rich dudes that
he's telling the bet on
um
yeah can you imagine finding out your
coach has been against you
like Weight Watchers and if he's even if
the Fighter's in on it too you know
because he just I guess he threw a leg
kick and that was pretty much it you got
too killed or killed
and he had a bad leg so that's kind of
it gets tricky and nobody can work with
him either they're saying if you
continue to work with me exactly that's
why it's so crazy so including our God
or your boy Brandon Marina so uh has
worked with a dozen Fighters including
flyweight champ Brian Moreno Grant
Dawson Tim Elliott Anthony Smith Laura
sanco Megan Anderson Jeff Molina
yeah you have to find new camp fellas
well she trains out of his gym oh okay
but I mean when she fought too and she
fought out of the gym but she still
trained it right
uh Cruz's miners long time coach was the
public face of one online bookmaker he
also ran a Discord server where he
advised fans on MMA bets after the
suspicious betting activity was flagged
by the UC betting Integrity firm he shut
down the service
Regulators have also zeroed in on miners
long time coach the former UFC fighter
shut down the server but he was banned
in New Jersey from BET on fights when he
was involved as a coach trainer promoter
of fighter several weeks before the UFC
Vegas 6-4 UFC moved to move to stop
fight waging my athletes on its roster
or via third Parties by making it part
of a we talked about that too
well that's what my thing with uh pierra
it's like when he's batting I'm like
well that's not good right now like we
mean
Pierre can't bet Alex or no Alex Pierre
okay when he was like oh my brother used
for charity oh that okay that's that's I
mean there's ways to go around it right
but still yeah
um meanwhile Regulators in Canada move
to cut off UC betting in general so that
[ __ ] the UFC and DraftKings and
everybody involved that's what I was
talking to Marcus they're losing money
oh because he's like what over this
minor kid and this Krause
here's the full letter from Hunter
Campbell per Arrow Hawaii yeah so Ariel
posted this stuff basically just saying
that he's banned and numbers he has to
move on from his Fighters
occasional athletes
um
so the UC athletic policy Express
prohibits UFC athletes from placing any
Wagers directly through a third party on
any UFC match including placing wages on
themselves the same uh
the installation also applied to an
athlete's coach manager Handler's
athletic trainers and other individuals
affiliate affiliated basically
affiliated with them anybody basically
because like say I'll still fighting my
brother couldn't do it no yeah I
couldn't even bet on you
um you'll see how since advised Krauss
and the respective managers working with
impacted Fighters that effective
immediately fighters who choose to
continue to be coached by Krauss or who
continue training his gym will not be
permitted to participate in the UFC
that's the crazy part
I think they found something else
further UFC has released Derek Minor
from the organization wow for just
having any relation to him as a coach
you can't fight in the UFC anymore boy
that's crazy yeah dicey
yeah
uh I mean What fighters like I'm
sticking by him dude so Moreno was he
posted something saying like uh you know
we'll see the truth later or whatever
he's he's standing by that's fine and
you say that be like but you gotta be
funny you gotta balance yeah and that's
his head coach he's gonna risk your
entire career on this guy's betting
habits I know it sucks dude you know
you're mine you're the the champion what
are you what are you doing
oof
yeah well I mean if I'm cross I'm just
like [ __ ] coaching if I make enough
money with that
[ __ ] coaching all right I was just
it's so when we first talked about this
I was like yeah maybe there's a me too I
defended him now I'm like yeah now it's
like dude yeah yeah if it's getting this
pretty
pretty deep of vfc's like anybody
associated with him is out holy [ __ ] and
then they cut homeboy they must have
known you they must know something more
than we do and on top of that says right
here Ontario suspends all betting on UFC
fights in Canada yeah and also Alberta
did the same thing so DraftKings UFC
just that's something so UFC is like
hell because they know there's something
wrong yeah or there's something wrong
here some something's happening well
they're like how deep is us go yeah you
know wow this is Brad Moreno
um yeah his post is hearing about this
whole thing with James cross he just
said waiting for justice
what would be Justice though
I mean I'm sure he decides UFC is never
gonna ever let James cross you know bet
on fights so if that's true then yeah
yeah so it's like justice for what if
the guy's batting and even if it's not a
legal [ __ ] which they you know it sounds
like goofy thinks that's what they're
good he's never gonna be able to bat the
UFC's never gonna let his Fighters
because he's so into that betting
business that's this huge thing it's
just a huge liability for the UFC and
with their deal with DraftKings and how
can this pulling out because like hold
on you let that guy coach guys no way so
it's just not worth the juice for the
UFC I'm like absolutely not he's not
allowed in it's gotten so far that there
has to be some sort of substance there I
agree
um love Bram Rayna hopefully it works
out yeah he's the best
all right so this was news as well Nate
Diaz officially Hits free agency oh now
they can have the negotiations with
Logan uh Jake Paul
um you know some of these other guys can
start to actually happen as soon as that
happened Jake Paul there you go yeah
because it was all illegal before that
and that's what he says hi Nate finally
have your UFC contract let's see how
tough you are in the Box ring instead of
hallway slap contest I have a venue
booked offers ready when you are just
need you to sign
yeah and who do you have on that Jake
yeah so do I yeah okay I think what's
interesting too because Nate and like
and the the Nate Diaz and Nate Diaz fan
base oh these are fake it's fake
well what narrative are you guys gonna
come up with when he beats Nate so if
it's all fake so then he's been
pretending this whole time but then the
one real fight was against your guy or
if it's fake this whole time you think
you see me the first time he's fighting
for real or is nada in on it too in your
whole scheme that would ruin his entire
image no it's so stupid yeah it's one of
the number one questions I get asked do
you think Drake's stuff is fixed like
holy [ __ ] that narrative
social media man it's like God you guys
try to figure out a way to tear a guy
down
and that's hate to see people win man
and the Anderson Silva knockdown that we
saw before remember we saw the different
angles one angle looked like he barely
got touched
Photoshop and then that gets passed
around online you know has whatever two
million views a lot of people didn't buy
the pay-per-view and I see that like oh
this stuff's fixed
boom that's the narrative Jake's like
this is [ __ ] so but what are you
gonna do because we know Nate sure as
hell he's gonna fix a fight it's not in
his DNA impossible to do so for you
doubters out there is the first real
fight you think Anderson Silva you think
Ben Astro you think Woodley the former
world champion all took Falls to build
the hive and just get a Payday or do you
think he's some weird world Jake Paul
trains his ass off and actually
connected on the punches do you think
it's some weird world Ben askren
freaking uh Anderson Silva Woodley
who are actual fighters fighters and
Hall of Famers do you think they realize
if they were to beat Jake Paul there's
actually more money in it for them
because they'd get a rematch or they'd
fight his brother or they could do
whatever the hell they want to do do you
think it's short side to think these
Legends would take a fall and a fix
fight you [ __ ] dummies yes yep
that's a tough fight for Nate it just is
what it is it's insane to say what we've
seen and before uh the Anson fight when
he was called out Nate I'm like Keith I
don't know if you want that we caught up
because being I'm like dude that ain't
what you want man
I'll just see him against instantly okay
yeah let's do it
yep
all right so this one
um so it turns out that
Charles Oliveira was offered a rematch
with marketev but interesting yeah but
he says according to his manager said
due to emotional stress he turned it
down he's still a break yeah he needs a
break yeah he's been grinding hard even
fighting the OC since he was 13. he just
needs to get his [ __ ] together and
I'll break's fine so I talked it
overdrived he's not injured but there's
emotional stress it's Way Beyond
physical Charles the only fighter that
has faced all the top five guys within a
year Champs normally hide they want to
fight once a year that's not Charles but
Rio is way too close now we prefer to
give Charles A well-dever deserved
vacation I love it I agree yeah
he's not going anywhere
break well earned indeed also tough
fight for him yeah right it's like it
was he got pretty technology was back
and forth yeah oh my God that's what got
me on the market Jeff train I'm like
okay real deal you guys were right I'm
in yep all of us
so this is uh so it's still not official
UFC wise but ajamin Sterling is
confirming that he is fighting Henry and
ali uh he said it earlier yeah yeah he's
like it's done and I just you know we
had Al Jermaine just here on food truck
watch to watch one of my favorite ones
and he got some great kicks for my boys
at suplex but
I was talking now Jermaine off here and
I was like you know the fight is sugar
like that's the biggest possible fight
you can get you want to get them now
because the trigger being placed in the
top two I think he's number one right
now
you know that Beyond fight was close so
there's a good chance somebody could
knock them down you want to get him was
his all-time high beat him it looks
great on your resume before somebody
else gets to him I'm not saying somebody
else is going to beat sugar but if they
are you want to be that guy you don't
want to wait to it's diminished and then
the the smoke isn't all over uh sugar
when you fight him you know you want to
get to him now so that's why it sounded
like he was gonna do and that was his
game plan you know with sahudo I just
you know sahudo was probably favored to
win the fights against Suga especially
and and against uh algebra it's a tough
fight for Al Joe
but I would ask this would say yeah I'm
not saying I'm gonna fight Henry we're
targeting March I will say Ali brother
it's done but still not done until
there's any other paper was done but
still kind of not done but this is the
fight that's going to happen next
weird it's done but still not done to
links on paper but it's done but still
kind of not done it's like it's done
contractually it's not done but so UFC's
probably like hey you guys want to find
March aljo says yes so who says yes they
go all right we'll put the counters
together they're just waiting for the
contract this fight is going to happen
obviously you guys saw the face off with
myself and so who do I have no problem
find Henry never talked to anybody in my
life do you see gives me the Tufts
competition I always step into play I
always win except for that one time when
I got sent to Neptune against one of
Marias for that most part I typically
went he's right
um
yeah I'm rooting for Al Joe on that I do
to me it's short side from the OC
because so so who's gonna come in
fight for the belt and then he's retired
right he's kind of moved on he's a
phenomenal coach
um he's still
heavy in social media so he stays
relevant but so he takes a belt from
algae and then what
maybe inside sugar yeah sure you're just
gonna wait it out she needs to just wait
for a title shot
you know yeah we'll see
and then just retire again and then the
bells just then we get aljo and sugar
down the road but they we've both seen
them lose to this guy yeah
question how sentencedo beat aljo
wrestling
right striking will be tough
yeah so yeah I'll just pray better
I'll just wrestling's not as good but
I'll just no [ __ ] joke
win that fight
all right so we talked about this last
week um Michael Chandler saying he wants
to do the BMF belt with Jorge Mazda and
Mazda doll says essentially that he
doesn't want to fight Chandler because
Chandler's a quitter and remember his
fight with the Challenge fight with Will
Brooks
this is in Bellator in Bellator yeah he
got rocked and he was like
like this that's it that's what that's
what yeah doing a throwback Thursday I
know we're talking about UFC you talking
about Bellator we're talking about
Bellator we're talking about Bellator
I'm talking about UFC
so here's BMF my ass that's the first
rule of being BMF you can't be a quitter
you might lose but you can't give up on
yourself you can't quit conversation for
BMF
BMF belt no it ain't happening come on
Joe I know you don't have a good
perception of the world but that's not
happening that's a bummer and he did
reference that whole will Brooks fight
back in the day Jesus Christ it was a
weird fight for sure
yeah I mean the guy in the ufcs must see
TV we're talking about right now hmm
we're not talking about who the baddest
[ __ ] was eight years ago yeah
everyone changes too and evolves
um so what do you think as far as the
opening odds for Jon Jones and in Ghana
uh I'm gonna ruin I saw uh John's
favorite right yeah he is favorite also
this is what I saw I'll put 10 G's on
Jon Jones
so as of now minus one that's why they
do this see they got me they got me they
want the lines to change they want to
put up money
yeah so minus 150 foreign
weird
interesting
yeah I I saw John's was a underdog and
I'm like oh well that's just because the
oddsmakers have no clue what type of
savage they're dealing with
easy to make money there
but I also bet on UC uh USC over Utah so
don't listen to me
all right this is
sort of an MMA world but so the guy the
oligarch who sponsored could be back in
the day yeah he was now he's now
sentenced to 19 years in Maximum
Security Prison because he was
embezzling State funds and he was part
of an organized criminal guard baby but
this whole garage can all look right so
his name's
um there's not a way it's
[Music]
z-i-y-a-v-u-d-i-n
dividend Mega medev 54 cents in 19 years
in Maximum Security Prison after being
found guilty on charges of embezzling
State funds and organizing a criminal
group the ruling which was announced
Thursday found that magamav and his
brother had embezzled to love
11 billion rubles which is 180 million
buckaroos from the state through land
real estate and other deals
but he was apparently young men was also
fined
2.5 million Rubles 41 000 restricted of
State Awards the older guys was once won
the richest men in Russia with an
estimated net worth of 1.2 billion
dollars as time was arrested on 18.
who arrests him Russia it has to be
Russia no
Russia Dave they're all guards they like
on the prisons
uh and plus he's connected to always
scroll down who reportedly showed in
some purse in the portion that you've
seen 2016. financial support uh several
Fighters including khabib even paid for
the former Champs Baxter in 2017. it's
done in Germany
um Monument was arrested a few weeks
prior to uh khabib's winning the library
Championship 2023
um
the newly crowned champ opted to use
this post by interview with Joe Rogan to
plead with Russian President Putin to
help magma our elder brother co-owner of
team I remember it was in a difficult
situation he's very helpful to me and
other athletes in Russia and I had his
problems but I want him to know that we
allow us to pray for him we have this
situation become resolved
see the thing awkward for khabib it's
like he doesn't know him as this you
know evil mastermind embezzler mob guy
he knows him as this oligarch with who's
a billionaire who paid for his back
surgery he's a nice guy you know
so I'm sure khabib's getting some heat
there it's like
you know my take on
um
the liver King which people had issues
with you got to realize you guys know
liver King based off whatever the
internet stuff like that I'm not on
there like you guys I don't have the
background in new when liver King walked
into the building that all his previous
interviews and the shows he's going on
to I'd I knew of him but I literally
like did my research
30 minutes before he walked in the door
I was like this guy sounds insane I was
like I wonder if it's a gimmick he wants
to give me a tool when he comes in I
knew nothing really about him I knew
Mark talked about him Brian would have
loot to him some people sent me videos
of him like you know eating liver and
balls and doing all this stuff and I was
like okay cool I guess we'll have them
on should be interesting then I meet him
he's a great guy I only know him I have
no other interaction I don't give a [ __ ]
about social media and YouTube and
Facebook and all that stuff that stuff
isn't real I know liver King the minute
he walked in a student I looked him in
the eyes shook his hand with no cameras
around I know that liver can great guy
great dad which I expect more anything
in the world so when I defend a guy
people like oh but he said this and he
made fun of people who were on PDS like
oh that that ain't good that's hard to
defend right it's like that's [ __ ] up
he probably shouldn't have done that his
apology not great you know he should
have been more from the heart but
um I think his team around him don't
realize the way maybe comes off a little
bit you know
um so again [ __ ] up made a mistake
apologizing we don't need this weird
thing on suicide and all that stuff
because that's going away from it I do
think his overall message is healthy and
inspires people to get in shape which is
I'm all about I also you gotta realize
my background is
I grew up around PDS and some people
that blow your mind if I said their name
it ruined their career who on PDS I just
assume everybody's on them at that level
especially in that field I I assume we
all know who's on it yeah but he's lying
yeah I know so it was everybody that's
ever sold supplements or have been on TV
or looks like that I assume they're on
[ __ ] that's not fair not everybody's on
stuff no you're right the majority are
them so to me when it came out I was
like how's this even news of course he's
on [ __ ] oh because he lied and then what
I didn't know before I defend him on
finding the kid is he's gone hard at
people that have taking Peds and
steroids he's like made fun of them and
stuff like that yeah okay yeah Brian
sent me this whole thing he's like man
you know maybe we should edit that part
I'm like no no at the time I didn't have
the information that's how I feel about
deliver kit I've talked to them since
he's a good guy I love that about you
now that you get yeah trust me I'm not
worried about taking heat but yeah you
don't want to edit [ __ ] out that's your
opinion yeah that's the time that's the
information you had even with knowing
all the facts now and seeing some of his
previous interviews stuff like that guy
[ __ ] up yeah I [ __ ] up for sure you
gotta be a [ __ ] I think that guy was on
anything or that's what I'm thinking too
like if you're broken-hearted that
deliver Kings on [ __ ] your favorite
actor your favorite athlete probably on
[ __ ] too you know they just don't get
asked those questions but
you know I think for liver King got out
of hand and he went about the wrong way
he needs to take ownership in that I'm
like yeah [ __ ] up I'm on [ __ ] at my
age I have to be and I have to look I
felt the pressure from look to look a
certain way otherwise you guys ain't
gonna buy my [ __ ] you know but it
doesn't mean his products or his message
is bad or fake or snake oil
you know what I'm saying like he's
actually a good person who did a
terrible thing and lied
but I will not Dogpile on people that
make mistakes and when we live in this
canceled culture where Society now the
cool thing is the [ __ ] on everybody take
somebody down if they're successful I
will not take part in that in any
capacity people make mistakes because
when you do that when you make a mistake
you're gonna wish somebody granted you
the freaking leash to come back and
apologize and give it another go you
don't get voted off the island I don't
know what the [ __ ] wrong with this
Society we live in where this can't it's
cool to cancel people and take away
their livelihoods like he has kids you
son of a [ __ ] I just I won't partake in
it and these people are [ __ ] on him
and you know so my friends are it's like
bro the people that you associate with
imagine if you kept that same energy
with the circle of friends that we have
the mistakes a lot of those people have
made keep that same energy yeah but I
know them cool so because you don't have
a personal connection with this guy he's
out because you know them you give them
the benefit of the doubt and how well do
you know those people that you say you
know
a lot of these people dog piling he's a
joke this guy's a piece of [ __ ] Jesus
Christ man keep that same energy with
these close friends or these people in
our Circle that have made mistakes you
gave them yeah I [ __ ] up and has to
own it but you're still his friend to
make him a bad person
well everything [ __ ] up man shouldn't
be lying shouldn't have done that should
have dealt it in a completely different
way all good liver King
learn your lesson take ownership put
your tail between your legs go back to
work
we don't vote them off the island we
don't think because he did that he's a
bad person or bad dad that's insane
got caught up in the famous caught up in
the hype
did not handle that right even his
apology I did not like his apology like
ah this should have been conducted so
you wrote some of this now get on
[ __ ] Instagram live like man I [ __ ]
up man I [ __ ] up boom own it then we
move on
free people are upset is austerity
[ __ ] stupid
I'm with you on that man who the f even
before the show remember we're talking
like we're not you're not gonna ask him
about Sarah so we know he's already on
we ever remember you me Brian Martin and
uh I forget maybe it's Mike or someone's
that go against terrorism of course he
is he's on obviously who the [ __ ] I I
was literally like of course he is why
would I ask him about that yeah and then
obviously
he says no so what do you well I'm just
getting ruin this that's crazy why do
you have to ask him you keep harping on
it yeah that's like Kim coming here
talking about my losses it's like wait
what are we doing you just want to talk
about [ __ ] I don't want to talk about I
don't want to do that and then you're
not getting a great interview because
then I shut down I'm like oh you I don't
feel safe with you you're going for
clickbait I don't feel safe now you're
not getting me being entertaining any
capacity when I go on other podcasts and
if it's they know they shouldn't talk
about they bring it up and it's like ooh
you [ __ ] up now now you're not getting
my best version now you're not getting
anything click baby now you're not
getting anything out of me now I don't
feel safe I don't trust you guys but I
don't want I must not it's also not my
job to expose him that's not what the
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] his message is
so by the way the way he treated every
single one of us so nice
uh off camera everything his him and his
team were [ __ ] awesome he even went
to when this came out he called me to uh
help him get on some shows which I did
and I told him uh and he was like man I
[ __ ] up I was like yeah he [ __ ] up
but own it get out there don't let the
internet beat you dude they beat you if
you stop
just keep putting out the good message
but put out the message with the truth
I'm whatever he is 42 years old or 44
years old there's no way I can look this
without some enhanced PDS but I still
have 30 years of hard work that got me
to this point but I do need some help
this is what I'm on but I'm also doing
this stuff
that's it Own It move on
don't let him steal your shine man don't
let them steal your energy then they win
that's exactly what they live for they
want to take your they want to take that
light out they won't take that wind out
of your sail because they could they'd
even [ __ ] enter the water they're on
the [ __ ] Coast shouting at you while
you're sailing to new heights on the
coast they would never even jump in the
boat
so they're triggered by your success you
know
but if you're gonna if you're gonna do
that he just has to be very open like
this is what I [ __ ] up this is why I
did it hopefully you guys can relate to
that if not my bad I apologize not a bad
person
yeah because you gotta draw the line
somewhere you think your politicians are
telling the truth all the time no and
plus the actors remember I even brought
up the whole Chris Hemsworth app thing
yeah because I'm like where do you draw
the line that's what I'm saying about
like but again the internet doesn't care
there it goes no we know some people are
fine online up here because they're cool
but that guy's not cool for whatever
reason they decide he's not cool a lot
of people do think he's cool because a
100 million dollar business but a lot of
people said he's not cool let's go after
this guy you know yeah so let's vote him
off the island yeah
and everyone's piling on right now I'm
like I'm still I won't partake in it no
I don't get it that [ __ ] I hate that
even with Fighters you won't listen
Darren Till's been an [ __ ] to me you
won't see me dog pounding until I'm
rooting for Darren till this weekend
you've always said that that stuff that
I have the thickest thing you've
thickest skin of anybody you've ever met
that stuff does not bother me yeah do it
dude you want some clicks put my name in
your headline go ahead dude I get it you
know I get it that doesn't bother me I
don't think he left it there until
well I'm sure it does hurt you a bit but
it's not gonna you're you've developed
this Scar Tissue yeah
because I've dealt with it for sure you
know before social media I dealt with it
and then trust me I know like going from
a football to fighter I dealt with it
all the time he's just a fighter did he
fight long enough oh he's just a fighter
then you go into comedy oh he's just a
fighter trying to do stand up and then
I'll stand up then it's on it's always
gonna be something
you just can't let them take the window
no sail you can't because they're on the
land they're not even the race so who
cares
that's my message uh uh liver King and I
did I help them as much as I can I told
him though he had he brought a program
that's not for you
that ain't gonna go well
wanting Rowan hates is a liar everyone
called from day one I was like why don't
you just tell people that's clear on
steroids
and Rogan with uh Derek from plates more
dates was like dude he's jacked I
I'm not this in any shade on liver King
you know I'm a big fan
he's not that jacked he's not that big
like his mask to me was in he was just
he's a smaller dude he's not I've I've
seen way more Jack guys at zoo culture
at the Olympia like I want to look at
him but God that guy's a [ __ ]
freaking nature nah older dude in shape
he's [ __ ] cow dick or whatever it is
you know like I didn't look at him like
yo this guy's a physical Freak No I
thought he was smaller than I thought I
thought he's gonna be it's definitely
smaller yeah
I think it's like crazy Jack is that
your thing but I was like he's in shape
smells like hummus
foreign
I mean all I know is when he was here he
was so cool to all of us that's that's
my memory of him my thing to him and his
great message too I connected him in
Schultz I said Schulte he needs a big
platform
my show the fighting the kid or with his
golden hour definitely not the thick boy
fight stuff it's just out of fit but
find a kid golden hour
because I'm such a fan of him I'm not
gonna ask him questions or get down to
the nitty-gritty I'm gonna be too nice
and people are gonna hate it you know
you need a bigger platform too so I I
said I think you should do Schultz's
show because Schultz
he's not in that lane but Schultz is a
smart dude and he'll do the research and
he'll take care of him but he'll also
give him what he needs he'll give him
that tough love and but also with other
dudes in the room with uh Akash and the
boys they'll have fun with it and they
come off good so I connect them Schulte
and I just connect him then my hands are
off she'll said I'm in Luke that's
awesome hopefully he gets done yeah
she'll just pray for that yeah have fun
with it I'll give him you know he's like
heavy dose Rogan and you like the in the
between yes yeah yeah yeah
like he's not getting a lot of just you
know
cake puff questions like a White House
convention thing yeah he's gonna he's
gonna Stick it to him
I just want to say one last thing about
this too I thought about this people
there's like arguments like even more
place more dates Derek was saying like
well he's he's purposely made himself
this way to sell products or whatever
yeah
I didn't do you know anyone that bought
products from other than the products he
gave us for free do you know of anyone
that liked him because of his products
or just did they like to no they liked
him yeah personality I don't know anyone
that brought us bought his products no I
don't like but I'm also do you mark dude
in like the gym do you know anybody
carry around his products do people buy
his products because they want to be
like him do you know anyone like that
that's a great point but I don't know
anyone
yeah
exactly dude I started eating Livermore
yeah like if he was a big fat guy I'm
like like I had a life this girls didn't
back in the day when I was different
shoot a life coach she's giving me
advice and then her power got cut off
she couldn't pay her power bills like
what are we doing here
that's you know what I'm saying so yeah
because Liberty is not jacked if liver
King's not jacked and in shape I mean
but also to your point chin he got big
as like uh a personality like we like to
see him I like his Instagram yeah I
wasn't like man I'm gonna do his diet oh
I want to buy stuff because he but I
like his message and the diamond kid
that makes sense I don't do like I do
carnivore but I'm not I thought that
stuff tastes horrible I'm like I'd
rather just be fat you know than eat
that but
um
yeah he's more of a personality he was
looking the part and when he says that
in his email he's like I'm about to
launch this thing you know I need to
look the part yeah and by the way come
on [ __ ] everybody does that [ __ ] not
every single person but everyone does
that if you're gonna be a selling
supplements about bodybuilding yeah
you're gonna do that most people would
do that yeah and also the the girl that
you jack off to every morning on
Instagram who's an influencer selling
skinny tea or whatever she's also fake
she's also fake or fake ass fake lips
outside that uses filters to look a
certain way so you want to follow her
yes it's the way Society is but for
whatever reason people go nope that
guy's triggering he's gotten too famous
too fast let's take him down yeah but
even though the message overall message
with liver King is all beautiful good
stuff to help people out that's the main
thing so maybe he made this facade to
like you know sell it but either way
it's positive everything he's doing is
positive and he he just sucks that he
got and here's to button this up at the
end of the day for those of you that are
whatever create new podcasts or your new
YouTube channel get on Instagram on
liver King
cool you know he's still worth a hundred
million dollars he was rich before he
still want he still won and you're still
in the situation you're in trying to
bring people down
nothing good comes from that no one's
ever built an Empire uh you know they've
never sent their kid to college based
off hey it just doesn't work that way
well the world does even though social
media makes it seem that way it just
doesn't yeah no long run you're never
gonna win do something yourself yeah
work on something make something do
something cool of course stop hating
yeah it's so lame
Al Jermaine Sterling had a great post on
Twitter because someone put uh Henderson
with his wife on his lap
it was a dope Photoshop I saw him like
oh [ __ ] that's dope and how's your main
goes this is good he goes he retweeted
he goes man this is good he goes you you
obviously dedicated a lot of time and
work this you have skill use think how
much further along you'd be along if you
put this in the right direction
because you're still in your current
situation whatever English can't be good
if you're trolling me he'll think how
much more better you'd be doing in life
if you put this as a positive spin
because you actually have talent you
know you have skill to do this stuff
like if you did a positive think what
you could do with your life God damn
good for you Al Joe I love Al Joe I love
them
I don't know how we got to a tiger I
know uh I'm sorry are you king I don't
know how we got to the liver King off
this oligarch but oligarch's gonna
oligard
oh I know how we got to it because
khabib doesn't know him as the criminal
mastermind he knows him as the nice
gentle guy who paid for his back surgery
and he defended me was like how dare you
do that that's like me and liver King I
don't know all his past what shows he's
been on what he's done before I know him
the second he walked in the store
smelled like Thomas and was a sweet dude
him and his team they're amazing great
yeah they're all great people yeah I
told him don't stop put the blinders on
keep going yep
I think that's it kids yep well you have
UFC 282 this Saturday which I gave you
my picks again I'll go over it Bryce
Mitchell for the win uh I think he's
done via decision maybe a submission but
tapiro's no punk on the ground but let's
say Bryce Mitchell Bryce Mitchell the
flat earther himself puts him flat on
his back gets it done uh Darren till I'm
room for Darren till do not bet on these
next two fights uh Darren till I want to
win I'm rooting for him I hope there
until beats duplicities but probably not
Robbie Lawler again Hobie wins probably
not against Punta nibio
um and then the people's Main Event
Patty pimlet uh Jared Gordon I'll take
Patty pimlet I think he steps up to the
to the platform man I think it's time to
shine and show out this guy's a good
test for him and I think it brings the
best out of Patty in front of his first
live ever crowd in Vegas so um I think
Patty gets it done odds are decision but
I'll say he gets it done via submission
late in the fight Patty predicted a
first round knockout but that's hope
here's the thing as Patty keeps going up
in competition he can't be taking those
hits and I told him that on the fight uh
food truck that uh it scares me how he
keeps getting hit but he's like it wakes
me up like I know you can get a certain
level where you're gonna wake him the
fight's over but Patty's gonna Patty so
the fifth Beatle is going to show out
gets the job done late via submission or
by decision more likely yawn blockage
versus magomed uh I'll take maguman I
think magmed gets it done via TKO
submission fourth fifth round but John
if you're yawn fan the prop bets on him
getting it done the first two rounds
Ain't a Bad Bet and then the thing I'm
most excited for is this Friday this
mother Trucking Friday uh almost said
February December 9th it's rough and
rowdy 19 in Providence Rhode Island you
have former NFL superstar Pac-Man Jones
versus lights out Lang all right you
have Barstool employee great face the
mick O'Malley brawling for the first
time all right it's their first female
ever influencer fight with Susie versus
Sarah all right and then uh the one I'm
most excited for you I've trapped Zilla
versus the American redneck all right
can't wait that's going down this
freaking Friday 5 p.m Pacific Time live
on thick boy and it again is Theo Von
Donald Cerrone the cowboy the living
legend Rampage Jackson and myself all
tune in to the thick boy YouTube Live 5
p.m this Friday Seasons beatings all
right that's rough and rally 19 bar
stool Sports get you some and then on
Saturday you have cobass fight campaign
Sam tripley Brian Cowan myself and a
very special guest I will announce
coming up so stay tuned I'll announce on
social media that goes down at 7 p.m
Pacific Time thick Boy YouTube
that's it kids oh we just restocked the
MLB quality thick boy jerseys they just
restocked this morning I just got told
so if you order them now you get them
just in time for Christmas so go get
them before they sell out those are
limited edition and uh oh they just add
the golden hour uh holiday sweatshirts
as well dope get you some thickboy.com
you can get your tiger thick whiskey if
you order it now you'll definitely get
it before Christmas and the MLB quality
jerseys just got restocked limited
edition get you some right now
thickboy.com all right all right love
you kids that's it enjoy the fights I
will see you Friday at 5 p.m Pacific on
thick boy for the rough and rowdy bar
stool companion and Saturday for the UFC
282 top ass fight companion uh on thick
boy YouTube and that's at 7 p.m Pacific
all right kids love ya see you next time
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding